This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方绝对无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持牌专业人士一起对话。多少男人身披铠甲。它向世界宣告，你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就非得这么做，请收听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以艰难的方式学习》。2%。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后，成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即“2%”，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信我，宝贝》（Trust me, babe）。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十岁时面临的重大生活改变与转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. It feels like there are a trillion little decisions that we need to make in our 20s. Some of them are nothing short of life-changing. And yet, when we find ourselves contemplating what path to take, where we possibly
大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身处世界何地。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听另一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析我们二十岁的心理。感觉我们在二十岁时需要做出成千上万个小决定。其中一些绝对是能改变人生的。然而，当我们发现自己在思考该走哪条路，最终可能
want to end up, it feels like we just simply have no idea. We have no idea what career path to take, who we want to be, where we want to live, who we want to be with, what we want to change in the next six months, let alone in the next five years. Instead, we get stuck in the space between where we are and making a choice, mulling over all of our options again and again and again, until quite frankly, none of them feel like the right fit. There is also this big emphasis in our 20s on taking risks, making big, big changes. But if you don't really know what you want, how can you even possibly choose what direction to take a risk in? I think a lot of us do have a problem with having the courage to take a chance on ourselves
想去哪里时，却感觉自己简直毫无头绪。我们根本不知道该选择哪条职业道路，想成为什么样的人，想住在哪里，想和谁在一起，未来六个月想改变什么，更不用说未来五年了。相反，我们被困在了现状与做出选择之间的空间里，一次又一次地反复权衡我们所有的选项，直到坦白说，它们中没有一个感觉像是真正合适的。在二十岁时，人们也极力强调要勇于冒险，做出重大、彻底的改变。但如果你连自己真正想要什么都不知道，又怎么可能知道该朝着哪个方向去冒险呢？我认为我们中的很多人确实存在这样一个问题，那就是缺乏勇气去为自己搏一把，
and to make those really, really huge decisions that are going to be life-changing. that is a problem of perhaps motivation, self-doubt, courage. But what if you can't even choose in the first place? What if it is almost impossible? You have two equally good options or equally bad options or there's just really no direction that seems to be calling you. Well, that is what I want to talk about today. What do we do when we are ready for a change,
并且做出那些真正会改变人生的重大决定。这可能是一个关于动机、自我怀疑、勇气的问题。但如果你连最初的选择都做不出呢？如果这几乎是不可能的呢？你有两个同样优秀的选项，或者同样糟糕的选项，或者真的没有任何一个方向在呼唤你。好吧，这就是我今天想谈论的内容。当我们准备好改变时，我们该怎么办，
but we just don't know how to get ourselves to the place of making a choice. I'm feeling this very strong pull towards a big life decision myself. I'm feeling a big pool towards moving to evolving, to starting something new. But the hardest thing for me to get over at least is just deciding. Making a choice between two, three, four options that all contain a different path, a different life. those are the kinds of hard decisions that I want us to really discuss today, the kinds of decisions where there is not one clear answer when we are seriously, utterly paralyzed with possibility.
但我们只是不知道该如何让自己走到做出选择这一步。我自己也对一个重大的生活决定产生了非常强烈的渴望。我有一种强烈的冲动想要搬家、想要蜕变、想要开启新的生活。但对我来说，最难克服的事情至少就是做出决定。在两个、三个、四个包含着不同道路、不同人生的选项中做出选择。这些就是我想让我们今天真正深入讨论的艰难决定，那种没有一个明确答案的决定，那种让我们被各种可能性彻底瘫痪的决定。
How is it that we move past this phase of indecision? How do we tap into what our subconscious is telling us that we really want? Because I do believe that deep down, we all know what we want when we're faced with a hard decision, we all know what is right to do despite conflicting interest, despite external factors, despite self-doubt. I want to talk about three exercises that we can use to really get to the bottom of a dilemma when it comes to hard decisions and what role, you know, fear and regret plays in this situation. So if you have been struggling to make a big life-changing choice in your 20s right now, I think you have come to the right place. I'm very excited for this episode. I know it's something that a lot of us encounter. I want to make a change. I want to
我们究竟是如何摆脱这种犹豫不决的阶段的？我们如何才能挖掘出潜意识真正想要告诉我们的东西？因为我相信，在内心深处，我们都知道自己真正想要什么。当面临艰难的决定时，我们都知道什么是正确的做法，尽管有利益冲突，尽管有外部因素，尽管有自我怀疑。我想谈谈三种练习，当我们在面对艰难决定时，我们可以利用它们来真正弄清困境的底细，以及恐惧和遗憾在这个过程中扮演了什么角色。所以，如果你目前正在为二十岁时无法做出重大且改变人生的选择而苦恼，我认为你来对地方了。我为这期节目感到非常兴奋。我知道这是我们许多人都遇到过的情况。我想改变。我想
evolve. I want to transform. But how exactly do I do that? How do I make a choice as to what direction to move in? That is exactly what we are going to be addressing today. So without further ado, let us discuss the psychology and some of the secrets around how to make hard decisions. Each of us at some stage in our 20s is going to come to a fork in the road where each road looks just as promising or just as difficult and we don't really know what to choose. The answer is not immediately obvious or even obvious upon a second or a third look and for lack of a better word, we just feel really, really stuck. We've asked everyone for advice, everyone's telling us different things, now it is time to trust ourselves. But instead of trusting
蜕变。我想转型。但我究竟该怎么做呢？我该如何抉择前进的方向？这正是我们今天要探讨的内容。废话不多说，让我们来探讨一下关于如何做出艰难决定的心理学以及其中的一些秘诀。在我们二十岁的某个阶段，每个人都会面临一个岔路口，每一条路看起来都同样充满希望或同样充满艰难，而我们真的不知道该如何选择。答案并不是立竿见影的，甚至看第二遍或第三遍时也不那么明显，用一个不恰当的词来形容，我们就是感到非常、非常的迷茫。我们向所有人征求了意见，每个人都告诉我们不同的话，现在是时候相信我们自己了。但是，我们没有选择相信
ourselves and going with our gut, we don't make a decision at all. We, if we're using the path analogy of two forks in the road, we just stop walking altogether. We're unable to take a step forward. What we don't always realize is that in that moment, delaying our decision, not making a choice at all, that is actually a decision in itself. And it is a much worse decision than actually choosing. The worst decision is no decision. But we get really, really caught up in the minute, small details and possibilities of what could come next. This is really what makes hard decisions differ in my mind to our everyday, or our medium, or our less significant decisions. They differ because of a few factors. First of all, the stakes are naturally really, really high. There are so many
自己并听从直觉，而是根本不做决定。如果我们用岔路口的道路比喻，我们直接停下脚步不走了。我们无法向前迈出一步。我们并不总是意识到的是，在那一刻，延迟我们的决定，根本不做选择，其实它本身就是一个决定。而且这比真正做出选择要糟糕得多。最糟糕的决定就是不做决定。但我们真的陷入了接下来可能发生的事情的微小细节和可能性中。这就是为什么在我看来，艰难的决定与我们的日常决定、中等程度决定或不太重要的决定有着本质的区别。它们因几个因素而异。首先，风险自然是非常非常高的。在人生的这个阶段，在这个十年里，有那么多
seemingly formative decisions to make during this period, during this decade of our lives. And it feels like each one really sets us on a course that we can't turn back from. Some big ones are like, what do I want to do as my career? Where do I want to invest my time? Do I want to invest in experiences, in education, in memories, in work? Same goes for finances. Where do I want to put? put my money, where do I want to put my love? All of these big dilemmas are really core to who we are and the future that we imagine for ourselves. So deciding on one option or between a bunch of equally good options feels paralyzing because again, the stakes are so high. Secondly, hard decisions usually have two or more equally appealing outcomes or two or more outcomes that
看似具有决定性的决定需要做出。而且感觉每一个决定都把我们推向了一条无法回头的航道。一些重大的决定比如：我的职业理想是什么？我想把时间投资在哪里？我想投资于体验、教育、记忆还是工作？财务方面也是如此。我想把钱放在哪里？我想把爱放在哪里？所有这些重大的困境都是我们核心身份以及我们为自己想象的未来的关键所在。因此，选择一个选项，或者在一堆同样优秀的选项中做出选择，会让人感到麻痹，因为再次强调，风险太高了。其次，艰难的决定通常有两个或更多同样有吸引力的结果，或者两个或更多的结果
kind of weigh up the same in your mind. That means, as we said before, it's not like the right choice immediately stands out. It does require more careful consideration and that is exactly where we tend to get stuck in the weeds. Finally, a hard decision contains a whole lot of fear attached to it. Specifically, I think a core fear of making the wrong choice, but with that also a lot of secondary fears like our fear of failure, our fear of regret, our fear of disappointing others, our fear of being judged, and our fear, wait for it, of an unhappy life. What is a bigger fear than that, really? A fear of an unhappy life is at the root of so many of our decisions and our dilemmas because, A, we obviously don't want that to happen, but I also feel like that in our 20s,
在你的脑海中分量相当。这意味着，正如我们之前所说，正确的选择并不会立刻脱颖而出。它确实需要更仔细的权衡，而这正是我们容易陷入泥潭的地方。最后，一个艰难的决定伴随着大量的恐惧。具体来说，我认为核心是对做出错误选择的恐惧，但随之而来的还有许多次要的恐惧，比如对失败的恐惧、对遗憾的恐惧、对让别人失望的恐惧、被评判的恐惧，以及——等着瞧吧——对过上不幸福生活的恐惧。还有什么比这更让人恐惧的呢？对过上不幸福生活的恐惧是我们许多决定和困境的根源，因为，第一，我们显然不希望这种事发生；但我也觉得，在二十岁时，
we don't, you know, we place a lot of care and a lot of our hope on some big major decisions and we haven't really had the life experience yet to know that it probably will and could go wrong, but we'll be okay anyways, right? We haven't had those instances of massive things collapsing and falling apart and realizing that we still have time to undo them. So stripping it back to the psychology, besides some of the reasons given above, why exactly is it that you and we both find it very hard to make hard choices in our life? Well, of course, the first idea we need to explore is choice overload. You're probably familiar with this concept if you listen to the show a lot, but for a refresher, choice overload is a psychological phenomenon where having too many options can lead to feeling. of anxiety, indecision, and eventually a dissatisfaction with the choice that we make.
我们不会，你知道的，我们将大量的关切和希望寄托在一些重大的决定上，而我们还没有足够的人生经验去明白，事情可能会也确实会出错，但无论如何我们都会没事的，对吧？我们还没有经历过那种天塌下来、一切分崩离析，却发现自己依然有时间去纠正它们的时刻。所以回归到心理学层面，除了上面提到的一些原因之外，为什么你和我们都会觉得在生活中做出艰难的选择非常困难呢？好吧，当然，我们要探讨的第一个概念是选择过载。如果你经常收听这个节目，你可能对这个概念很熟悉，但作为复习，选择过载是一种心理现象，即拥有太多的选项会导致焦虑、
So this concept is also known as the paradox of choice. I love that paradox of choice. And it suggests that we often, you know, think that having more choices will make us happier and lead to a better outcome because we have more freedom to choose. But actually, too many options overwhelm us. And it makes it harder to make a decision or feel content with the one that we eventually choose because there are all like there's just so many what ifs there are so many more um kind of places where our imagination can take us as to what our life could have been like
犹豫不决，并最终对我们做出的选择感到不满意。所以这个概念也被称为选择悖论。我喜欢这个选择悖论。它表明，我们经常，你知道的，认为拥有更多的选择会让我们更快乐，并带来更好的结果，因为我们有更多的自由去选择。但实际上，太多的选项让我们应接不暇。它让我们更难做出决定，或者对我们最终选择的结果感到满意，因为有太多——这里有太多的“如果”，有太多让我们的想象力驰骋的地方，去想象我们的生活本来可以是什么样的。
think about um choosing a choosing a grad job or any job even choosing a career path insert your own here nowadays so many of us including myself are so lucky that we don't have to just simply do whatever our parents did before us, as was the case with basically every generation that's come before. We have a lot more freedom, but having so many opportunities and being able to see all these different lives that others are living online, on LinkedIn, in, I don't know, the paper, no one really reads the paper anymore, magazines, maybe TikTok, being able to see all those different options does something to our brain and it overloads it. because now there is just so many more comparisons, so many more pros and cons, cost-benefit analyses
想想，呃，选择一份研究生工作，或者任何工作，甚至是选择一条职业道路，把你自己代入其中。如今，我们中的许多人，包括我自己，都非常幸运，不必简单地重复我们父母过去所做的事情，就像前几代人基本上经历的那样。我们拥有更多的自由，但拥有如此多的机会，并且能够看到其他人在线上、在领英（LinkedIn）、在——我不知道，报纸上（其实现在没人读报纸了）、杂志上、也许是TikTok上——过的所有这些不同的人生，对我们的大脑产生了一种影响，让它超载了。因为现在有了更多的比较，更多的利弊权衡，
that our brain has to do. And because of that potential contained in each option, it feels like none of them is ever going to leave us completely satisfied and we are haunted by the what-ifs or the what-could-have-beens. So they did a study on this specifically in 20-something-year-olds recently, or what they called at the time emerging adults. And it found that although this period of our life is characterized by abundance and liberty and freedom and choice, more of us are unhappy now with the path, specifically the career path that we've chosen compared to previous generations, primarily because of how many other better futures we are able to imagine for ourselves nowadays.
成本效益分析需要我们的大脑去处理。正因为每个选项中所包含的潜力，感觉它们中没有一个能让我们完全满意，我们被“如果……会怎样”或“本可以怎样”的假设所纠缠。因此，最近一项专门针对20多岁年轻人的研究——或者当时被称为新兴成年人（emerging adults）的研究——发现，尽管我们生命中的这一时期以丰裕、自由、自主和选择为特征，但与前几代人相比，我们当中现在对所选择的道路（特别是职业道路）感到不幸福的人更多了，这主要是因为我们现在能够为自己想象出许多其他更好的未来。
It's ironic, right? You know, shouldn't it make for a happier life? Isn't this what everyone was working towards, letting people have choice, letting people have freedom, letting people have opportunity? Actually, no, because that's not how our brain works. Our brain actually has this natural instinct called a loss aversion, whereby we tend to think over and obsess on all our possibility for loss rather than our gains. So in this example, we spend a lot more time ruminating over the life that we could have had rather than being grateful for the one that did eventuate. There is an amazing book that talks about this in such a comforting and beautiful and gentle way. And it's called the Midnight Library. This is a fiction book. So it's not the usual self-help or non-fiction that I recommend. But it follows this woman who gets the opportunity to be.
这很具有讽刺意味，对吧？你知道的，这难道不应该带来更幸福的生活吗？难道这不正是每个人都在努力争取的目标吗——让人拥有选择、让人拥有自由、让人拥有机会？实际上，并没有，因为人类的大脑不是这样运作的。我们的大脑实际上有一种叫做“损失厌恶”（loss aversion）的本能，因此我们倾向于过度思考和沉溺于所有可能损失的可能性，而不是我们的收益。所以在这样一个例子中，我们花更多的时间去反刍我们本可以拥有的生活，而不是对最终实现的生活心存感激。有一本非常棒的书，以如此舒适、美丽和温柔的方式探讨了这一点。它叫做《午夜图书馆》（The Midnight Library）。这是一本小说。所以它不是我通常推荐的自助书或非虚构读物。但它讲述了一个女人的故事，她有机会
basically live out all her possible lives. She is someone who is very overwhelmed by regret for where she is, where she's at in her life currently. And she gets to go back and see how life would have turned out if at some point she'd chosen differently, if she had become a professional swimmer, a scientist, a performing artist. And what's so beautiful about this book is that it basically shows that we spend so much time sometimes fantasizing about what could have been, not realizing that nothing ever turns out the way that we plan. It's an amazing read, especially if you're someone who deals with a lot of analysis paralysis. I think I just loaned it to my friend Kate because it was so good.
基本上过完她所有可能的人生。她是一个对现状、对她目前的生活感到非常遗憾的人。她得以回头去看，如果当初在某些时候她做出了不同的选择，生活会变成什么样，如果她成为了一名职业游泳运动员、科学家或表演艺术家。这本书的美妙之处在于，它基本上向我们展示了有时我们花太多时间去幻想可能发生的事情，却没有意识到事情从来不会按照我们计划的那样发展。这是一本必读之作，特别是如果你是一个经常陷入分析瘫痪（analysis paralysis）的人。我想我刚刚把它借给了我的朋友凯特，因为它太棒了。
So I would highly recommend. But, you know, the paradox of choice is why you find it hard to make decisions. decisions. We also tend to catastrophize more than we should, especially if you're someone with an anxious mind. You're an overthinker. You're an overachiever. You're a perfectionist. And what that means is that, you know, when we have to make a choice, when we have to do something that's hard, we imagine that it's going to turn out way, way worse than it does. One of the best mindset shifts that I've ever adopted, ever, is that when my brain is catastrophizing, it is doing so to protect me, not to scare me, not to make me fearful, it's not logical, it's just a suggestion, it's just my
所以我强烈推荐。但是，你知道的，选择悖论就是你发现很难做出决定的原因。我们还倾向于比实际情况进行更多的灾难化思考，特别是如果你是一个焦虑型人格的人。你是一个过度思考者。你是一个过度成就者。你是一个完美主义者。这意味着，你知道的，当我们必须做出选择，当我们必须做一些困难的事情时，我们想象事情的发展会比实际情况糟糕得多。我采用过的最好的心态转变之一，真的是最好的，就是当我的大脑在进行灾难化思考时，它这样做是为了保护我，而不是吓唬我，不是让我感到恐惧，这不是逻辑，这只是一种建议，这只是我的
brain trying to worry for me so that I won't eventually come across the situation I'm not prepared for. How I see it is that this instinct, this mental experience, this mental experience, is testing me to see if I'm capable. And just by acknowledging the potential worst case scenario, but choosing to proceed anyway, I'm proving that I am capable because I've acknowledged it and I've accepted it that that is something that could happen, but I'm going to go forward anyways.
大脑在试图为我担心，这样我最终就不会遇到毫无准备的情况。我的看法是，这种本能、这种心理体验、这种心理体验，是在考验我是否有能力应对。只要承认潜在的最坏情况，但依然选择继续前进，我就在证明自己是有能力应对的，因为我已经承认并接受了这种可能发生的情况，但我还是要继续前行。
The other thing that I realize is that, and this is something that's important, if you catastrophize a lot, if you're faced with a bunch of decisions and you're like, well, if I choose this one, it's going to turn out terribly. You know what I mean. If you catastrophize, I want you to remember, not all of your worst case scenarios can possibly come true. It's so interesting, our brain often gives us like a million different situations that could happen,
我意识到的另一件事是，这也是很重要的一点，如果你经常进行灾难化思考，如果你面临一堆决定，并且你在想，好吧，如果我选择了这个，结果会一团糟。你知道我的意思。如果你进行了灾难化思考，我希望你记住，你所有的最坏情况不可能全部成真。这太有趣了，我们的大脑经常给我们提供数百万种可能发生的情况，
a million different equally terrible hypotheticals. They can't all come true and yet we're feeling the fear of them all. You really have to be able to distinguish in those moments between a fear-based hypothetical and a practical assumption that will help you. It's interesting because research published in the Harvard Business Review, I think last year, suggests that we tend to catastrophize because it is a way to regain control in an uncertain world or in an uncertain time by trying to predict as best as we can what might come next.
数百万种同样糟糕的假设。它们不可能全部成真，然而我们却对它们所有情况都感到恐惧。在那些时刻，你真的必须能够区分基于恐惧的假设和能够帮助你的实际假设。有趣的是，哈佛商业评论（Harvard Business Review）去年发表的一项研究表明，我们倾向于进行灾难化思考，因为这是在不确定的世界或不确定的时期重新获得控制权的一种方式，方法是通过尽最大努力预测接下来可能会发生什么。
So, you know, if you're at a crossroads in your life, that is a very uncertain time for you. but by catastrophizing kind of makes it feel like you have a bit more control than you do. But these doomsday scenarios in which we lose everything, we fail miserably, we end up alone, we ruin our life, it's really just our brain's limbic system trying to alert us to any and all potential dangers, including those that are literally never going to happen. Because, you know, our brain is like, but what if they do? What if the 0.00001% occurs?
所以，你知道的，如果你正处于人生的十字路口，那对你来说是一个非常不确定的时期。但通过灾难化思考，会让你觉得你比实际情况拥有更多的控制权。但这些我们失去一切、惨败、最终孤独终老、毁了我们一生的世界末日场景，其实只是我们大脑的边缘系统在试图向我们发出任何及所有潜在危险的警报，包括那些实际上永远不会发生的危险。因为，你知道的，我们大脑的想法是，但如果它们真的发生了呢？如果那0.00001%的概率发生了呢？
Well, at least I'll know I'll be mentally prepared, or at least I'll think that I'm mentally prepared. Our choice to catastrophize when it comes to hard decisions, it also isn't random, right? It's a learned behavior that has its roots in anxiety and also in past trauma, in perfectionist tendencies and our need for control. people who have this tendency to catastrophize, we often put a lot of pressure in ourselves to
好吧，至少我知道我会在心理上做好准备，或者至少我认为自己在心理上做好了准备。我们在面对艰难决定时选择进行灾难化思考，也并非随机的，对吧？这是一种习得的行为，其根源在于焦虑，也根源于过去的创伤、完美主义倾向以及我们对控制的需求。拥有这种灾难化倾向的人，我们经常给自己施加很大的压力，
achieve an outcome that is perfect or that is going to reflect very favorably on us. And unconsciously, actually, it's not that we want the best outcome, it's that we're terrified of an imperfect outcome. We're terrified with how we're going to be able to cope. At some stage, what we've learnt as well is that, thinking about a decision and a problem repetitively without actually doing anything is quite self-soothing because we feel like we're doing something about a problem or a situation by over-analyzing it without actually having to do anything. And that is the real tricky thing to remember.
去追求一个完美的结果，或者一个能非常有利地反映我们自身的结果。而不由自主地，实际上，并不是我们想要最好的结果，而是我们对不完美的结果感到恐惧。我们对我们将如何应对感到恐惧。在某个阶段，我们还学到的是，反复思考一个决定和问题而不采取任何行动，具有相当的自我安慰作用，因为我们觉得通过过度分析一个问题或情况，我们正在为它做些什么，而实际上并不需要做任何事情。而这正是需要记住的真正棘手的事情。
You think you're doing something. You think that you're helping yourself by doing all your pros and cons list. You're actually not. It's become part of our emotional toolkit. if we are feeling stressed or overwhelmed by a decision, if we think about it for as long as possible and we come up with every alternative, well then of course there's no way that we're going to get it wrong. It's interesting to me to consider this as a offshoot of anxiety because we know that the opposite of anxiety is actually trust. When we trust ourselves enough to know that whatever happens we will be okay, we can make those hard decisions quicker. We know that we can trust ourselves that if we lose that relationship, we're going to be okay.
你以为你在做些什么。你以为通过列出所有的优缺点清单，你是在帮助自己。其实你并没有。它已经成为我们情感工具箱的一部分，如果我们对某个决定感到压力或不知所措，如果我们尽可能长时间地思考它并想出每一个替代方案，那么当然，我们就绝不可能弄错。在我看来，将其视为焦虑的一个分支很有意思，因为我们知道焦虑的相反面其实是信任。当我们足够信任自己，知道无论发生什么我们都会好起来时，我们就能更快地做出那些艰难的决定。我们知道我们可以相信自己，如果我们失去了那段关系，我们会好起来的。
If that job is not what we really wanted, we trust ourselves to be able to find something better. If that decision turns out absolutely, horrifically, terribly wrong, we trust ourselves that we will make it work. And that is what gives us the courage to really go after what we truly want. So if you are struggling with making hard decisions, it's probably because at some point that's self-trust was injured or damaged. For me, I remember when my self-trust was basically, you know, blown to smithereens. It was this one big failure that I had when I was younger. And I felt so judged and I could see that I'd done something wrong. And it just made me feel like, you know, I could never trust myself again. Because in that moment, I'd believe,
如果那份工作不是我们真正想要的，我们相信自己能够找到更好的。如果那个决定结果绝对、可怕、糟糕地出错了，我们相信自己能够让它步入正轨。而这正是给我们勇气去真正追求我们真正想要的东西的原因。因此，如果你正在努力做出艰难的决定，那可能是因为在某个时刻，这种对自己的信任受到了伤害或破坏。对我来说，我记得我的自我信任基本上，你知道的，粉碎得粉碎。那是我年轻时经历的一场巨大的失败。我觉得自己受到了极大的评判，我能看出自己做错了事。这让我觉得，你知道的，我再也不能相信自己了。因为在那一刻，我相信，
that I was doing the right thing and that wasn't true. You know, for others, your self-trust may be injured by excessive criticism or having a really overbearing parent, boss, friend who corrects everything that you do. And basically that external criticism is taken on board by our inner critic and it's spoken back to us in our own voice. It becomes self-imposed. Trauma and betrayal as well. that is something that really leaves you doubting your own ability and capability. It also has this secondary influence on self-esteem as well. There's a really fascinating study that was conducted in 2018 and they got over 100 individuals to complete a self-esteem and a self-trust scale, basically saying,
我正在做正确的事情，而事实并非如此。你知道的，对其他人来说，你的自我信任可能会因为过度的批评，或者有一个非常专横的父母、老板、朋友而受到伤害，他们会纠正你做的每一件事。基本上，这种外部批评被我们的内在批评者全盘接受，并用我们自己的声音回荡给我们。它变成了自我强加的。创伤和背叛也是如此。这确实会让你怀疑自己的能力和效能。它对自尊心也有这种次要的影响。2018年进行了一项非常迷人的研究，他们让100多名个人完成了一份自尊和自我信任量表，基本上是在说：
how do you feel about yourself and do you trust yourself? And then they got them to basically participate in this experimental, would you rather situation where they were asked to choose between three scenarios. One, which was really, really risky. I think the payoff, although the likelihood of the good option happening was 20%. One which was somewhat risky. That was around 50%. And one that was completely, it just wasn't a risk at all.
你对自己的感觉如何？你信任自己吗？然后他们让他们参与到这个实验性的“你更愿意怎样”的情境中，要求他们在三个场景中做出选择。第一个场景风险非常非常高。我想回报很大，尽管发生好选项的可能性只有20%。第二个场景有一定风险。概率大约是50%。第三个场景完全谈不上风险，
It was a certain outcome. the people who had reported that they had poorer self-esteem and that they trusted themselves less, they would choose the sure option almost every single time. They literally would never even consider taking the risk because they didn't trust themselves. They didn't trust themselves that if the risky decision outcome did happen that they would be able to go on. Even in the situations and the circumstances where the risky decision, the one with the 20, 30% and the 50% likelihood, we're going to provide them with much bigger payoffs. They wouldn't do it. I think that that really applies to real life as well, to everyday situations, where you're going
这是一个确定的结果。那些报告自己自尊心较差、对自己的信任较少的人，几乎每一次都会选择确定的选项。他们甚至根本不会考虑承担风险，因为他们不信任自己。他们不信任自己，如果高风险决定的结果真的发生了，他们是否能够继续坚持下去。即使在那些高风险决定（概率为20%、30%和50%）能为他们带来大得多的回报的情境和情况下，他们也不会这么做。我认为这同样适用于现实生活，适用于日常情况，如果你不相信无论发生什么，无论有多少未知数，你依然会好起来的，
to really struggle making a hard choice in your life and a hard decision. If you don't try, trust that no matter what happens, no matter the unknowns, you're still going to be okay. One final reason that I found from experience that we struggle making hard decisions during this decade is because of a conflict or attention as well between passion and practicality. Feels like this generation is divided into people who take career progression really seriously, who are very financially stable and cautious and happy working their nine to five and want that security versus this other group of people who are, you know, very committed to seeing the seven wonders of the modern world to starting businesses and brands and changing jobs
那么你在生活中做出艰难的选择和艰难的决定时，将会非常挣扎。我从经验中发现，我们在这一十年里难以做出艰难决定的另一个原因是激情与实用性之间的冲突或张力。感觉这一代人分为两类人，一类是认真对待职业发展、财务状况非常稳定谨慎、乐于做朝九晚五的工作并渴望这种安全感的人；另一类人是，你知道的，非常热衷于去看看现代世界的七大奇迹、创立企业和品牌、在感觉合适时更换工作
and careers when they feel like it, putting everything into their dream, taking their time. Neither is better or worse than the other. And some might say it's personality, but I actually think, you know, each of us has it in us to pursue the risky path and to do, and to make the decision to, you know, not necessarily follow our dreams but to put everything on the line. But there is this tension and a personal battle we all face between what we're really passionate about and what we know is practically necessary to have a successful life. Who do we want to be? Which path do we want to choose? That is the other reason that it's hard to make big life choices. Are they going to dictate where you're going to
和职业、把所有东西都投入到自己的梦想中、不急于求成的人。这两种人没有孰优孰劣。有些人可能会说这是性格问题，但我实际上认为，你知道的，我们每个人内心都有追求风险道路的潜能，去做出决定，不是非要追逐梦想，而是把一切都押上。但我们所有人都面临着这样一种张力和内心斗争：一方面是我们真正热情所在，另一方面是我们知道过上成功生活实际所需的东西。我们想成为谁？我们想选择哪条路？这是很难做出重大生活选择的另一个原因。它们会决定你最终会走向何方吗？因为在我们内心深处，存在着对两种截然不同的人生轨迹的两种巨大的渴望。
end up because there are these like two really big desires within us for two very different, different lives. So what I want to discuss next is how to cut through the noise and really tell what you want, really be able to determine what path is right for you and have the courage to follow through, whatever it may be. All of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2% I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts,
所以我接下来要讨论的是，如何穿透噪音，真正认清自己想要什么，真正能够确定哪条路适合你，并有勇气坚持到底，无论那可能是什么。这一切以及更多内容，在短暂停留之后揭晓。2%。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家对话，
and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got to at wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
以及更多内容，以看清主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们在这点上弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即“2%”，可在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all right, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've just That's correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Now you're finishing that sentence.
需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，但只是为了让你们都明白， literalmente。但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们第二期只讨论——没错。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在了台面上。现在你把那句话说完了。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了样东西，
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而我们却仍在追逐，并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于赢与输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），你觉得作为一个活在世上的好人很重要吗？你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself,
完全正确。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯（Keir Gaines），让我们在我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》中，进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的i Heart Radio应用程序。搜索《以艰难的方式学习》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己，
at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives
处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的不一致之处。这开启了长达数年的诉讼之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大军，
to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. The Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
才能破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过同样事情的男士。吉莱斯皮（Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子都炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县（Americopa County）突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When it comes to making hard decisions, there are a couple of strategies that people will kind of always throw your way. Like, let me think. The classic ones are make a pro cons list, talk to people you trust, do a cost-benefit analysis. These are very, very useful. And I do think they'll get you closer to a decision, but sometimes these decisions aren't something that we can really be rational about. There's something that we can't hear other people's opinions about. We need
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。当面临艰难的决定时，总会有一些策略是人们总是会向你抛出的。比如，让我想想。经典的策略是列出优缺点清单、与你信任的人交谈、做成本效益分析。这些非常非常有用。我也认为它们会让你更接近决定，但有时这些决定并不是我们可以理性对待的事情。有些事情是我们无法听取别人意见的。我们需要
to trust ourselves? Well, it is my belief that deep down, we all kind of know what we want. Our desired outcome, choice, dream life, dream choice. It's already in us. It's just that it's shrouded in these clouds and this mist of self-doubt, of fear, of expectation, of what's safe, what we think we should be doing. Think about the decision to break up with a long-term partner. That's a very hard decision some of us face. On the surface, you might think, you know, they are such a good person. All of my friends like them. It would be so hard to start dating again.
相信自己？好吧，我相信，在内心深处，我们其实都知道自己想要什么。我们渴望的结果、选择、梦想的生活、梦想的选择。它已经存在于我们体内了。只是它被自我怀疑、恐惧、期望、什么是安全的选择、我们认为自己应该做什么的这些云雾所笼罩。想想与长期伴侣分手的决定。这是我们有些人面临的一个非常艰难的决定。表面上看，你可能会想，你知道的，他们是个很好的人。我所有的朋友都喜欢他们。重新开始约会将会非常困难。
I'm scared I'll never find anyone. But when you wade through all these fear-based thoughts, at your core, you know what you want. You know what you want. That's why you're trying to give yourself excuses because you know that once you decide it's going to be really, really difficult. In fact, I think if you're asking the question, some part of you already has the answer. If you're asking yourself, should I move overseas? You know, I have the opportunity. Should I do it? You already know the answer. Should I quit my job and take this new opportunity, even if it's a bit scary? You already know the answer. In psychology, we often conceptualize
我害怕我再也找不到任何人了。但当你拨开所有这些基于恐惧的想法时，在你的内心深处，你知道自己想要什么。你知道自己想要什么。这就是为什么你一直在给自己找借口，因为你知道一旦你做出决定，过程将会非常非常艰难。事实上，我认为如果你提出了这个问题，你的内心深处其实已经有了答案。如果你问自己，我应该搬到海外去吗？你知道的，我有这个机会。我应该这么做吗？你心里已经有答案了。我应该辞掉工作去抓住这个新机会吗，哪怕它有点吓人？你心里已经有答案了。在心理学中，我们经常将
this part of us as the subconscious. It's the part of us that holds our purest emotions, our purist desires, needs. It's the most unadulterated, real true version of us. The subconscious knows. And that means that you know. Deep down, you do. So how do we tap into that? Well, the first exercise I want you to try is what I call the wisest self scenario. It's as it sounds. Imagine yourself in the future 10, 20, 30 years down the line as the wisest version of you. You and who you could become. Picture yourself having lived through challenges, learn from mistakes,
这部分自己概念化为潜意识。这是保存着我们最纯粹情感、最纯粹欲望、需求的部分。它是最纯粹、最真实、最本质的我们。潜意识是知道的。这意味着你知道。在内心深处，你确实知道。那么我们如何挖掘这一点呢？好吧，我要你尝试的第一个练习是我称之为“最明智的自我场景”。听起来就是这样。想象一下你自己，在未来10年、20年、30年后的某个时刻，作为最明智版本的自己。你以及你可能成为的人。想象自己经历过挑战，从错误中吸取了教训，
and gain just invaluable experience. That future self has clarity. They have patience, they have a deep understanding. You trust them, remember? You trust them. Now ask this version of you, what would you have me do right now? What choice should I make?
并获得了无价的经验。那个未来的自我拥有清晰的视野。他们有耐心，有深刻的理解。你信任他们，记得吗？你信任他们。现在问问这个版本的你，你会让我现在做什么？我应该做出什么选择？
What's your advice? by consulting your wisest self, you tap into a perspective that really transcends the current emotions or pressures that are clouding your decision making. This exercise allows you to kind of step out of the present day stress and connect with a version of you who doesn't have anything to do with that right now. Who doesn't really care? A version of you who has lived through it knows you'll survive and who can kind of come back and tell you what you really need to do. And this method works because of something called psychological distancing. You put space between your emotions and the decision so that you can identify what you really want.
你的建议是什么？通过咨询你最明智的自我，你可以调动一种真正超越当前情绪或压力的视角，而正是这些情绪或压力在模糊你的决策。这个练习能让你暂时跳出现实生活中的压力，与一个与此毫无关系的自己建立联系。那个完全不在乎这些的人呢？那个已经经历过这一切、深知你能挺过来、并且能回来告诉你你到底该怎么做的自己。这种方法之所以奏效，是因为有一个概念叫心理距离。你在自己的情感和决策之间留出了空间，以便你能确定自己真正想要的是什么。
Another reason is that, you know, the reason it helps us make not only a decision, but the right decision comes down to this concept called future self-continuity. And this basically says that people who feel more connected. to their future selves are more likely to make decisions that benefit their long-term well-being. Visualizing yourself as a wiser version, it also promotes empathy and kindness and love towards your current self, who's really gone through it, who has really got a lot of wild thoughts going on. And that enhances yourself trust because you kind of, if you trust this future version of
另一个原因在于，你知道，它之所以能帮助我们不仅做出决定，而且做出正确的决定，归根结底是因为一个叫做未来自我连贯性的概念。这基本上说明，那些感觉与未来的自己联系更紧密的人，更有可能做出有利于其长期福祉的决定。将自己想象成一个更明智的版本，也能促进对当前自己的同理心、善良和爱，现在的你真的经历了许多，内心确实有许多天马行空的想法。这会增强你的自信，因为某种程度上，如果你信任未来这个版本的
yourself, you have to trust that right now, you, you know, you are the foundation. of that future wise version of you. You're the one who's going to become them. And so they cannot be wise without you making choices, right? Does that kind of make sense? Like they cannot be, they could not be as wise as they are if you didn't trust yourself right now. And if you weren't capable of getting to that point. If this isn't your cup of tea, I totally get it. Another version of this that I love in which my own incredible therapist introduced to me a few years back is the 10, 10, 10, 10 rule. It's pretty simple. Say you have two, three decisions you're contemplating. Should I move to a new city even though I don't know anyone? Or should I stay here where I'm comfortable? I don't really know what to do.
你自己，你就必须相信，此刻的你，你知道的，你就是未来那个明智的自己的基石。你就是那个将要成为他们的人。因此，如果没有你做出的选择，他们就不可能变得明智，对吧？这听起来是不是有点道理？就像他们不可能达到现在的智慧，如果你现在不信任自己的话。如果你当时没有能力达到那个点。如果这不合你的胃口，我完全理解。我非常喜欢另一个版本的做法，几年前我那不可思议的治疗师向我介绍了这个方法，那就是10、10、10、10法则。这很简单。假设你有两三个正在考虑的决定。我应该搬到一个新城市吗，即使我谁也不认识？还是应该留在这里，过着舒适的生活？我真的不知道该怎么做。
Do I, you know, stay safe or do I stretch out my comfort zone? I want you to ask yourself, how are you going to feel about either decision in 10 days, in 10 months and 10 years from now? in 10 days when the initial anxiety is passed, what do you think you'll feel? In 10 months, how much do you think you will have grown in either environment? In 10 years, could either of these decisions become a regret for you? Will it be a turning point for you? Will it be something that you look back on and say, gosh, I just wish that I'd go on with my gut and done the hard thing and done the scary thing?
我是，你知道的，保持安全还是扩展我的舒适区？我想让你问问自己，从现在起10天、10个月和10年后，你对这两个决定会有什么感觉？在10天后，当最初的焦虑过去时，你觉得你会作何感想？在10个月后，你觉得自己在任何一个环境中成长了多少？在10年后，这些决定中的任何一个会让你感到后悔吗？这会成为你的转折点吗？这会成为你回头看时说：“天哪，我真希望当初能听从直觉，去做那件艰难的事，去做那件可怕的事”的事情吗？
regret, like this kind of regret, factors into decision-making more than we realize, because we are kind of haunted by this understanding that we can't go back. We can't go back and change the decisions from our past. There is no time machine. And that works both ways. We can't go back and tell ourselves what we know now and prevent a bad choice, but we also can't go back and change our trajectory to a better course. How I like to frame this is what is the risk of trying to.
后悔，比如这种后悔，对决策的影响比我们意识到的要大，因为我们总是被一种“无法回头”的认识所困扰。我们无法回到过去，改变我们过去的决定。世上没有时光机。这在两个方向上都适用。我们无法回到过去，告诉自己我们现在所知道的事情来阻止一个糟糕的选择，但我们也无法回到过去，将我们的轨迹改变到一个更好的方向。我喜欢这样来构架这个问题：尝试的风险是什么？
compared to the risk of doing nothing. I'm just going to say it one more time. What is the risk of trying versus the risk of doing nothing? Often we get stuck in indecision out of fear of making the wrong choice, but in reality, there is often a much greater risk contained in staying stagnant and staying the same. The risk of doing nothing can lead to missed opportunities can lead to regret and a lack of growth, the risk of trying, even if it leads to failure, will still bring about learning,
相比于什么都不做的风险。我要再强调一遍。尝试的风险与什么都不做的风险相比如何？通常，我们由于害怕做出错误的选择而陷入犹豫不决的境地，但实际上，停滞不前和保持原状往往蕴含着更大的风险。什么都不做的风险会导致错失良机，导致遗憾和缺乏成长，而尝试的风险，即使导致失败，仍然会带来学习、
experiences, the possibility of success. When we frame decisions this way, it becomes clear that taking action no matter how uncertain often outweighs the regret of never knowing what could have been. If you have a decision that is bugging you, that is weighing heavily on your mind and your heart, please prioritize action over inaction every time. As the saying goes, you want to feel the fear and do it anyways. And I reflect on so many examples of this in my own life and in my own timeline. You know, the time I moved away for university at 17, the time I quit my full-time job to do the podcast full-time, the time I moved to Sydney, fresh out of a relationship, more lonely than I've ever been and I had so many doubts and I was so terrified and I did it anyways.
经验以及成功的可能。当我们这样看待决策时，就很明显了：无论多么不确定，采取行动往往胜过永远不知道“如果……会怎样”的遗憾。如果你有一个让你烦恼、沉重压在你心头和脑海里的决定，请每一次都把行动置于不采取行动之上。俗话说，你要感受恐惧，但依然要去做。我回顾了自己生命中和时间线上的许多这样的例子。你知道的，我17岁时搬去外地上大学的那次，我辞去全职工作全职做播客的那次，我刚结束一段恋情就搬到悉尼的那次，那是我前所未有的孤独，我曾有过那么多的怀疑，我感到无比恐惧，但我还是去做了。
And you know what? Things did go wrong. Things did go wrong and I was lonely and I did struggle and it was really, really hard but there is not a single day in any of those scenarios that I would go back and tell myself, tell my past self, no, just sit tight. Don't do anything here. This isn't your time to make a change because every single time I'm so glad that I did it. I'm so glad that I chose action over inaction. On that note, I also think we can benefit from reflecting on previous times where you felt paralysed and you've made a decision anyway. Think really hard about a decision that you've previously made and all the catastrophes that your brain cooked up beforehand. You know, when I moved to Sydney, I can distinctly remember worrying about, oh my God, what if I have to
你知道吗？事情确实出了差错。事情确实出了差错，我很孤独，我也确实在挣扎，那段日子真的、真的很艰难，但在任何一种情况下，我都没有哪怕一天想要回到过去告诉自己，告诉过去的自己，不，就在这里稳住。不要在这里做任何改变。现在不是你做出改变的时候，因为每一次我都为自己做了这件事而感到无比庆幸。我无比庆幸自己选择了行动而不是无所作为。顺便说一句，我也认为我们可以从反思以往那些你感到瘫痪但最终还是做出决定的时刻中获益。好好想想你以前做过的决定，以及你大脑事先臆想出的所有灾难。你知道的，当我搬到悉尼时，我能清楚地记得自己一直在担心，天哪，如果我不得不
move back? What if I never meet anyone? What if I run out of money that spiled into, you know, What if I lose touch with all my friends? What if I end up alone? And the ball just kept rolling and rolling and rolling. And none of those things came true. Our own experiences are our best teacher. Because we lived through it. We have the evidence right there.
搬回来怎么办？如果我永远遇不到任何人怎么办？如果我的钱花光了怎么办，这演变成，你知道的，如果我和所有的朋友失去联系怎么办？如果我最后孤身一人怎么办？然后这种担忧就像滚雪球一样越滚越大。但这些事情都没有发生。我们自己的经历是最好的老师。因为我们经历过。证据就摆在那里。
And this brings about such a crucial perspective to your choices. If it's fear that is holding you back, remember that fear is natural and a protective response, but it's also inaccurate and you have seen many times before the ways in which fear may have kept you small or fear was trying to lie to you. Finally, and I promise I'll wrap it up soon, but just I love talking about this. And this is my final piece of advice for the day, I promise. And it might sound very counterintuitive to everything that we've discussed so far. But I just want to say, don't worry too much about the big decisions. Don't let them get any bigger than they deserve. There are very
这给你的选择带来了一种至关重要的视角。如果是恐惧在阻碍你前进，请记住，恐惧是自然的，是一种保护性的反应，但它也是不准确的，你以前已经多次见证过恐惧如何让你变得渺小，或者恐惧试图对你撒谎。最后，我保证我很快就会结束，但我只是太喜欢谈论这个了。这是我今天给你的最后一条建议，我保证。它可能听起来与我们迄今为止讨论的一切都非常反直觉。但我只想说，不要太担心重大决定。不要让它们变得比它们应有的更重要。在一整天或当场做出的选择中，
very few choices we can make in a single day or on the spot that is irreparably going to alter our life. You know, maybe like drunk driving or like doing something dangerous or criminal, that's one of them. But, you know, other huge, ginormous decisions, a lot of those choices can be undone. We can find our way back. We can always course correct. What's more valuable actually is the small everyday decisions that build our life kind of stone by stone, brick by brick, our daily habits, our small moments where it becomes easier and where we push ourselves and where we just stay curious to what is possible.
极少有哪个能不可挽回地改变我们的生活。你知道的，也许就像酒后驾车或做一些危险或犯罪的事情，那是其中之一。但是，你知道的，其他巨大的、庞大的决定，其中许多选择是可以撤销的。我们可以找到回去的路。我们总是可以纠正航向。实际上更有价值的是那些日常的小决定，它们像石头叠石头、砖块砌砖块一样构建了我们的生活，我们的日常习惯，我们那些变得更容易、我们挑战自己、我们对可能性保持好奇的小时刻。
Our life is really made in the small choices and yet we spend so much time worrying about the big things, often not focusing on the small ways in which we have, you know, chosen to stay stagnant. the small decisions that, on the other hand, completely alter our life. So don't get too caught up in the big things. Don't rush them either, but don't, you know, be spending weeks and months considering because by the time you might be ready, the opportunity could have passed. Remember action over inaction. Remember to be able to identify when you were catastrophizing
我们的生活确实是由一个个小选择构成的，然而我们却花那么多时间去担心大事，往往没有关注那些我们选择保持停滞不另一方面，那些彻底改变我们生活的小决定。所以不要过分纠结于大事。也不要催促它们，但是，你知道的，不要花数周和数月的时间去考虑，因为等你准备好的时候，机会可能已经过去了。记住行动胜过不行动。记住要能够识别什么时候你在灾难化思维，
and when it is a fear-based thought rather than a practical thought And above all else, please trust yourself. Trust yourself. The root of indecision is a lack of self-trust. And you can counter that by allowing yourself to make mistakes and allowing yourself to just go with your gut instinct and affirming time and time again, no matter what happens, I am going to be okay
什么时候这是一种基于恐惧的想法，而不是一种实际的想法。最重要的是，请相信你自己。相信你自己。优柔寡断的根源在于缺乏自信。你可以通过允许自己犯错、允许自己顺从直觉并一次又一次地肯定“无论发生什么，我都不会有事”来对抗这种心态，
because that is the truth. I want to thank you all for listening to today's episode. I know that these decisions can feel excruciatingly large, but the fact that you care enough about your future to be thinking about it at all. It's a good sign that you're going to be totally fine. You're going to make the right choice. You're going to be able to figure it out whatever happens. If there is someone in your life who you think needs to hear this episode, please send
因为这就是事实。我要感谢大家收听今天的节目。我知道这些决定可能会让人感到痛苦地重大，但你足够关心自己的未来去思考它这件事本身。就是一个好兆头，说明你完全没问题。你会做出正确的选择。无论发生什么，你都能搞定。如果你生命中有人需要听听这期节目，请把链接发给
them a link. Make sure that you are following along for future episodes. And if you would like to leave a five-star review, if you feel called to do so, it would be greatly, greatly appreciated. We read every single one and it's just so amazing the community that we are building. If you have a future suggestion, you can send that to me on Instagram at That Psychology podcast, just slide into the DMs. We do take a lot of inspiration from you guys, the listeners. So we would love to hear from you and make sure that you are following us over there. Until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle to yourself, make that hard decision. You've got it. I know.
他们。确保关注以后的节目。如果你愿意留下五星好评，如果你觉得有必要这样做，我们将不胜感激。我们会阅读每一条评论，我们正在建设的这个社区是如此神奇。如果你有未来的建议，你可以在Instagram上发私信给我，账号是That Psychology podcast。我们确实从你们这些听众身上汲取了很多灵感。所以我们很想听到你们的声音，并确保你们也在那里关注我们。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，做出那个艰难的决定。你能行的。我知道
you can do it. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast 2% that's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator
你能做到。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难一课》。这个空间关乎黑人的经历，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全但必须坦诚相待的对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你需要收听iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的《艰难一课》2%——这就是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例
available i'm michael easter and on my podcast 2% i break down the science of mental toughness fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier more fulfilled healthier person Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇异的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians,
从1979年开始，这对当时的我是个重要时刻。1984年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、其他喜剧演员、
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important, year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
以及喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证是由真人创作的。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。